conventional wisdom for the past 50
years has been that we get fat because
we take in more calories and we expend
so this idea that exercise is crucial to
lose weight or to maintain weight comes
out of this idea that obesity is an
energy balance problem I do believe the
exercise is inherent part of a healthy
lifestyle but the idea is if someone's
healthy they're going to want to be
physically active and if they're
unhealthy if they have the metabolic
syndrome if they're gaining weight and
their heart disease risk is going up a
symptom of that is being sedentary in
effect when you increase expenditure you
increase your desire to eat more we got
into this idea that obesity is an energy
balance disorder that it's just about
taking in too many calories if it's
about taking it in too many calories the
solution is to expend more how do you
expend more you exercise therefore we
should all exercise and in the process
of embracing that we forgot the exercise
builds up an appetite doctors would tell
their patients like you know play two
sets of tennis today and build up an
appetite go for a walk you're not eating
enough you got to build up an appetite
what do you do exercise and then it got
shifted into you're way too much what do
you do exercise and the evidence
suggests that doesn't work it might make
you feel better makes us stronger I work
out regularly but there's precious
little annex evidence that you could
lose weight by doing it